IF TARIFFS ARE RETALIATED
AGAINST US.
CHRIS, BACK TO YOU.
>> Chris: DEIRDRE, THANK YOU.
THERE IS A MAJOR SHAKE-UP
TONIGHT ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM.
HIS LEAD ATTORNEY AND SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION HAS RESIGNED.
CATHERIN HERRIDGE SPOKE TO JOHN
DOWD TODAY ABOUT WHY.
>> catherin: JOHN DOWD ON THE
RUSSIA PROBE THIS MORNING, THE
PRESIDENT GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED.
HE EXCLUSIVELY TOLD FOX NEWS THE
PRESIDENT HAS A TERRIFIC CASE
AND HAS PROVED IT TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM IN SPADES.
DOWD DEFENDED HIS WEEKEND
STATEMENT CALLING ON THE DEPUTY
GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO
WANTED ROBERT MUELLER TO END IT,
SAYING THE STATEMENT IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I HAVE TOLD
MUELLER AND HIS INVESTIGATORS ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
I AM SO PROUD OF THE PRESIDENT'S
TRANSPARENCY AND HOW ANYONE
AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
EXTRAORDINARY COOPERATION IS
BEYOND ME.
WHILE DOWD WOULD NOT COMMENT ON
LEGAL STRATEGY, FOX NEWS LEARNED
THERE WAS DISAGREEMENT ON
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT SHOULD SIT
WITH AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AFTER SIGNING A PRESIDENTIAL
ORDER IMPOSING TARIFFS, A
REPORTER RAISED THE ISSUE.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY TO
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER,
SIR?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO.
>> Catherin: TYE COB, AND OTHER
ATTORNEYS, WHILE TOP LITIGATOR
TED OLSEN TURNED DOWN AN OFFER.
PROVIDED WITNESSES AND RECORDS
ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS RAISING THE
QUESTION WHY THE PRESIDENT
NEEDED THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INTERVIEW WHILE OTHERS CAN
ANSWER HIS QUESTIONS.
ON CAPITOL HILL, MIXED REACTIONS
AND WARNINGS.
>> I AM NOT OVERWHELMED BY THE
ALLEGATION OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
WHAT I HAVE SEEN IS A PRESIDENT
WHO GETS FIXATED ON THE
INVESTIGATION AND HE SAYS THINGS
THAT CREATE LEGAL ISSUES FOR
HIM.
>> IF YOU SHUT DOWN OR THROTTLE